hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 7th 2018 what's going on how
is yeah how's it going how are you is
your hockey team still alive in the NHL
playoffs well you know what because mine
isn't mine is not mine is done for the
goddamn season I do want yeah yeah no
[ __ ] consideration for the high level
of quality of a program that's going on
in here
why would you do that you come in here
and you apologize to the incredible
intellect of my listeners oh my god Mia
can we sit down and talk about how you
cut up that steak last night Oh were you
running
what are you running to listen to this
you want to talk about one of one of the
shadiest moods ever moves ever come here
sit down sit down gorgeous well bring
her in here it'll take some of the sting
out of what I'm gonna say to you so
anyway so we go out you know a friend of
ours in town and of course she wanted me
our lovely beautiful absolutely charming
always in a great mood gorgeous daughter
right now we love showing her off we
love getting the compliments oh my god I
know right
I did that you know I didn't I took a
half-court shot and God did the rest
anyways so we end up going out to a
steak house right Sania it's like I
don't want it steak but I'd like some
steak are you gonna order a steak and
it's like yes When in Rome hi hi did you
say hi to me you say hi to the listeners
cutie so he is just like you kind of get
a steak I don't want
crap the lump crab cake which is what
you ordered so what does ol freckles do
where does old freckles do Kiki orders
of course what do you order Oh Billy
steak face I ordered the bone-in rib how
the hell did that happen sorry
what just happened there somehow I moved
in the volume got turned down anyways
I'll have to edit that part out so
anyways old Billy steak face i order a
bone-in rib eye
so cutie pie here starts getting
frustrated yeah I starts making noise
and I you know I don't wanna be that guy
at the restaurant with the baby that's
crying especially in a steak house a
steak house you have a lot of people
there in their second marriages people
who you know didn't get married guys who
are paying for a house that they're no
longer allowed to go into you know
there's a lot of that go in there you
know a lot of child support being paid
you know by some of these people who had
to rebuild it again so let's look at you
belly hanging out look at you belly
hanging out what are you doing so she
was my daughter was getting frustrated
so I just started I started you know
walking her around the restaurant and
everything like that being the amazing
father that I am right
running around she's so short I gotta
like you know bend at that angle that
it's like killing my back but I but I
stuck it out I did it for you I did it
for all those divorcees in there right
all those people playing child support
even though women that we're gonna
starting to pay child support to you
haven't seen that you don't read that in
Cosmo they're complaining that which I
love I love this whole Equal Pay cause
you waiting you you wait till enough
women have to start paying child support
and you watch those so anyways while I'm
being the amazing father that I am
obviously this is my this is my version
of the story my steak arrives
Sonia goes to cut off her portion of the
steak and basically what she does is she
cuts the thing like lengthwise right a
lot like an inch away from the bow
and she takes all the meat along the
bone and then gives me the rest of it
for those you who aren't meat eaters all
you vegetarians out there the most
flavorful part of a bone-in ribeye the
reason is is all along the bone and she
took the best meat and I was so upset
with her I told her that she needed to
go to ancestry.com because that was some
northern white European [ __ ] what you
just did there yeah I took the yeah I
did that's my favorite part know if you
want to know what it's like to be a
husband and a father that's what it is
she makes the baby she goes through all
of that she goes through nine months of
hell ten months of hell actually there's
the middle three that's like the summer
vacation but whatever we'll say ten
months a hell and you know what and then
as a guy you pay for it for the rest of
the relationship she gets it all back
with little little shady cuts of bone
and rib eye I couldn't believe that hi
hi cutie yeah well you know what and
I'll be in love with her till the day
she takes the good part of my Cheerios
all right hi how are you cutie all right
daddy has to talk filthy so I can still
buy your diapers that's how it works I'm
sorry I'm too far down this road to
pretend that you have a respectable dad
all right lovely ladies well I mean I
thought that you were gonna try to
defend your position and you didn't
you're like yeah I did that's that's
what I did
you're doing Donald Trump right now
that's how he got out of stuff you said
all this horrible stuff about women he
was like I said that about Rosie
O'Donnell they were like no you said
that about other women he was like yeah
you're probably right
it's like all right I thought that was
gonna be a big funny fight you know
there was nothing a you're on my ankle
okay all right ladies
bye-bye cue say bye-bye bye-bye all
right oh well yeah I'll see you later
okay
let me guess McDonald's what do you guys
what what do you like Betty like
McDonald's or Burger King a boy I've
always been a McDonald's guy no he's
been McDonald's and it's not like I'm
out here looking for another advertiser
I'll tell you right now I feel the best
poison in fast food is McDonald's this
is how I would I would run this how I
rank my fast-food cheeseburgers Mia
all right as much as just some great
ones out there like in and out I have to
go to McDonald's because the child
sense-memory you know that just takes me
back to you know when my bicycle was
orange just like my hair that I used to
have and I had the white tape around the
handlebars huh I went to the to see my
trainer and when I got it oh yeah did
you take the best mat in the gym yes and
he was finishing up with another client
and she had her daughter there who was
like 4 years old and she's so cute so I
said oh we want to see pictures of my
baby and so I was showing her pictures
of the baby and then she saw a picture
of you with the baby and she was that
and I said oh that's um her daddy that's
my husband and she goes okay shows why
doesn't he have any hair we've said that
the kid get the poor girl and I said
well you know sometimes when people get
older
their hair starts to come out and so he
just decided to cut it off because he
didn't want it just to be falling out
and I think it looks better this way and
she was like yeah that's true why did I
need to know that that wasn't cute I
already feel bad enough about myself
do me kids have looked at me and said
you're ugly in my life at least six no I
swear to God when I had hair yeah
children and children are honest I know
what all you adults are doing you just
being nice to me maybe you deserved that
bone-in rib eye just give me the ship
Rai ya ugly get out of here yeah cute
story Mia yeah yeah hey I met this girl
the other day and she I showed her a
picture you and she was like hey why is
her butt so big and I was like well you
know you but isn't big alright but now
I'm gonna [ __ ] pay for you're gonna
laugh at that and I'm gonna pay for that
comment forever right you could just you
could just eviscerate me perfect it is
it's why I married you
sure wasn't certainly wasn't the other
end I have no problem with this you have
the [ __ ] yep that drives me up the
wall
alright whatever why do I try to make a
point why do I try to get ahead you know
what I mean it's just like Bill you
losing okay you're at a casino and the
house always wins and the house is your
[ __ ] wife so just [ __ ] cash in
your chips and go back to the goddamn
room anyways let's get back to the NHL
playoff congratulations to the [ __ ]
expansion Tampa Bay Lightning I don't
hate you guys because I love Steve
Yzerman and I know he's in your front
office so I'm happy for him all right
okay having said that you guys worked
the better team no matter how bad the
officiating was it was bad
both sides and no matter what I think
you guys still you're just wearability
you just repetitive no matter what
you're gonna win but I will say this
this officiating straight across the
board in the NHL playoffs not just
arguing for my team has been really
unprofessional really unprofessional
there's always a couple of calls here
are there but like it's reminding me of
NBA officiating last decade when I'm not
saying it's fixed this is coming off
more like I feel like it's like did the
real refs go on strike and these are
like some [ __ ] scab refs they pulled
out of the [ __ ] crowd it was just a
couple of like look you know Marshawn
took that guy's [ __ ] knees out they
didn't make a call there which I thought
was [ __ ] and you know I know we were
licking people's faces and there's no
rule against that yet I can guarantee
you
maybe now that the Bruins have knocked
out maybe they'll relax but I mean I
thought if we advance to the next round
they were gonna make a quick rule it's
gonna be called a Marshawn rule it's
going to be no player shall kiss lick
tongue or in any manner use his facial
orifice with inappropriate contact
there's gonna be there's got to be the
Brad Marchand rule and someday if I live
long enough I will see Brad when he's in
his 70s on the NHL Network laughing
about it talking about how that rule
came about and why he was doing what he
was doing
it's the most bizarre thing I've ever
seen and it was it was it was hilarious
when they went back to the studio Jeremy
Roenick was it was like it happened to
him he's like I would immediately gone
to the showers and I was thinking like
oh that's great you're a Hall of Fame
player let's get you off the ice I had a
buddy of mine actually text me said not
even Sean Avery licked another player
and I was like yeah well he was too dumb
to think of it and he goes well if he's
that dumb why is he married to a
supermodel and I
fair enough you got me anyways but just
you know I mean what the [ __ ] the guy in
tamp like we really needed to win Game
four so we couldn't lose in six games he
was still gonna lose the [ __ ] Tampa
gay is his hands off his dick he hauls
McAvoy down behind his own net behind
his own [ __ ] net no call it was it
was the most obvious not only did he
announces when they went back to the
[ __ ] studio even they were like what
the [ __ ]
Tampa takes it pass it over stamp coast
and they tie the [ __ ] game up and we
instead of having a chance to even this
series at 2-2 we go down 3-1 it was just
stuff like that I you know it's funny as
bartnik was in Tampa Bay and he was
listening to it on the radio and
Esposito said that it looked like a dive
which is the funniest [ __ ] thing ever
Esposito is still [ __ ] pissed that he
asked for like $3.00 more from the
cheap-ass boston bruins 45 years ago and
they shipped them to New York our
archrival other than the Canadiens
during that time so he will never be
impartial when it comes to us but what
the [ __ ] kind of who the [ __ ] is gonna
dive behind their own net with the puck
behind your own [ __ ] net when you're
up by one and you have to win that
playoff game are you gonna go down three
games to one I don't know here's
Esposito he is a hall-of-famer but that
did not look like a dive to me and
haven't said all this [ __ ] sour grape
[ __ ] I know Tampa still would have won I
know they probably would have won the
probably six games is what I think would
have happened they just had too much
firepower and I think by the time we
decided to get physical in the series it
was too late but that's what was missing
in our game this year I think against
Toronto and against Tampa which both of
them I felt had more firepower than we
did is when you're playing a team that
has you know as faster than you and has
more gold scores you have to get
physical with them you can't just let
him [ __ ] skate around and I think we
just waited too long but haven't said
that this rebuild is on an upswing I
mean I thought that we were going to be
bad for a good six seven seasons I
didn't
see the light at the end of the tunnel
so I'm very happy that we won a playoff
series advance to the second round
definitely a very successful year and
we're gonna have a new rule named after
one of our players to Marchand rule
[Laughter]
maybe it's a good thing that we lost in
five if there was any more games he
might have been the first guy to get a
[ __ ] me two case from another guy
right oh no no wait that one guy did the
agent did with the other guy from the
cop show alright I guess everything's
been done is that what it is has
everything been done in the whole time
this is what kills me is I'm watching
the Bruins you know just [ __ ] lose in
this series licking people's faces and
[ __ ] and I've missed every single second
of the Celtics 76ers you know I just I
had to pick a road I'm so busy I got the
kid and all that and I only had time and
I missed I guess one of the most epic
Celtics games in recent memory where
they tied it up at the buzzer against
the Sixers and then came back and won in
overtime all I'm hearing is Rozier Tatum
Brown how much they're stepping up Al
Horford I guess was blocking shots like
a maniac and so now I got a I got I
guess I have I have all the time in the
world to watch the Celtics now so I so I
kind of realized you know as much as I
love the Celtics and everything I really
am a hockey guy because I knew we were
gonna lose that series and I still hung
in there and watch it although I missed
yesterday's game because I was at a kid
birthday party an awesome kid birthday
party like you know you know when
parents doing a kid birthday party right
you take notes these people did it great
they didn't have it at their house they
had it at like a function room there was
an outdoor area there was a little jumpy
house this guy did a bubble show you
know he had a good set too man that's a
tough crowd you know kids trying to keep
them you know their attention they had
booze for the parents they had great
food you know and then over in the
corner they had this area where the kids
you know one of those play pens that has
like a zillion you know different
multi-coloured balls and all that type
in it's just my kid was totally
entertained
the whole time I don't think I saw any
kid crying just until the very end with
the kids you know they need a nap and
they're just like but it was a great
time so somebody ever asked me cuz you
Bruins playing right now Michael afraid
to look it's always kind of looking down
looking at the scores and then all my
Boston friends were sending me texts
going what the [ __ ] are we doing these
refs suck the refs really did suck you
know who knows they probably still would
have maybe tied it up and beat us in
five who the [ __ ] knows but I'm just
saying you know I just hate having that
like that goddamn feeling you know
that's like that year the Lakers beat us
you know which sucks enough but if the
Lakers beat it's fine
I can live with that they're the [ __ ]
Lakers you know what I mean but you know
you call like 30-something flowes on one
team and you know in the teens on the
other and a game seven
it's just inexcusable unless we were out
there hacking people up and it's just I
don't know [ __ ] drives me up the
goddamn those are the ones that stay
with me you know what I mean I don't
give a [ __ ] if you just come in and kick
our ass but you know I but I do take
peace in the fact that Tampa Bay was
definitely the better team and I feel
that them easily could have just beat us
in six as much as I hate to admit any
[ __ ] anyways plowing ahead
what's going to go on with the Capitals
or the Capitals finally going to get
over the hump and slay the dragon and
beat these goddamn penguins from
Pittsburgh for the Pittsburgh Penguins
going to continue their march to be the
first team since the New York Islanders
as Steve bird reminded me yesterday
since the New York Islanders to win
three in a row and spend that long the
Islanders actually won four in a row
from 80 to 84 and I remember that month
they were on the cover the next year
Sports Illustrated and then said the
strive for five just you know the rate
one of the rare times Sports Illustrated
put a hockey player back then you know
on the cover and I think was Mike Bossy
if I remember correctly and
yeah that was the age of dynasties when
I grew up when I think about it from
like you look at the 70s in hockey
Bruins won two Flyers one two and the
Canadiens won six so you had three teams
basically won everything and then the
previous decade it was it was Canadiens
Leafs and then the Blackhawks won one
and then I think Canadiens won five and
and the least one for because I want to
say the least one like three in a row
and then one in 67 and the Blackhawks
won is 61 and everything else was the
Canadiens if I remember correctly and
then he went to the 80s then the
Islanders so basically after the and
when Bruins Canadiens Bruins Canadiens
Flyers Flyers then Canadians Canadians
Canadians Canadians and Islanders
Islanders Islanders Islanders Edmonton
Edmonton Canadiens Edmonton Edmonton
then Calgary beat the [ __ ] Canadians
at one of my favorite one Lanny McDonald
the ginger and then Edmonton again in 90
and then 91 92 was the Penguins and that
was like I mean you're talking a I mean
you could literally go back all the way
to the 50s because I know like the Red
Wings one like back-to-back and
everything else was just it was just
[ __ ] basically pre-1967 if you had to
guess who won the cup that year either
guessed Canadians or Maple Leafs but
then all of a sudden you know once you
know they had the expansion six and
sixty seven and then they added a you
know Edmonton Oilers and all those guys
in like I believe 78 or something like
that
and then it was a 28 team league and it
just took a little bit well actually the
Islanders were an expansion team in the
early 70s then they got a low that went
on that run
but uh then after that after the
Penguins went back-to-back it's just
basically but every other year it's like
somebody else wins it
other than that when the Red Wings won
two in a row and I think the Penguins
right now right it's not how it goes
I don't [ __ ] know but anyways which
is why I hate to say this is a Celtics
fan I think the the Lakers are they
they're the most successful franchise in
the modern era because they were able to
during free agency win championships at
a clip that people won before you know
back when it was like you know if you
were a Laker you were a Laker go [ __ ]
yourself you're not going somewhere else
unless the owner decides they haven't
said that you know the Lakers do have a
championship you know there was a
mobbed-up ref and [ __ ] over the
Sacramento Kings that year I'm not
saying the Kings would have won it but
the Lakers would not have gotten a
banner that year and then that other one
with the [ __ ] 30-something fouls 37
files and 48 minutes of the Celtics I
never forget Kobe he goes I don't know
how we won that game well [ __ ] talk
to the guys with the athlete's foot
shirts anyways sorry I'm just in a
[ __ ] bad mood because my team lost
[Music]
anyways plowing ahead here Oh Billy no
vice trudging along into May I wanted to
go at least a week into me because I was
just trying to go you know the month of
April basically vice --less and then I
got into May and then I'm just like you
know what I'm looking good
I'm keeping the weight off I got the big
5o next month it would really be a shame
if I got this close to my birthday
looking this good and then I just you
know I just [ __ ] you know put on that
booze 10 pounds I don't want to do that
but so I've been laying off laying off
board his [ __ ] went to that party
yesterday there was booze there could I
had one didn't do it went to the steak
house
they had all the beautiful [ __ ]
bottles behind the bar
didn't do it came home trudged past my
bar they don't even say hi anymore
didn't do it went downstairs took out my
phone played solitaire on it and fell
asleep the exciting life of sobriety you
know it's hard to as I watched the
Kentucky Derby
I wouldn't want money because I always
bet on that white haired guys horse
because he's just the man he's the Bill
Belichick of that [ __ ] and the year I
went the only time I went was that
Triple Crown winner and he owned it I
won money on that one and I was thinking
if I was there I was I always the
Michael McDonald guy of the horse racing
owners and I was just watching that's
that event and I was just I was like why
am I not sitting here right now drinking
some bourbon smoking a cigar right
watching it through my front window the
volume turned up she can't smoke a cigar
in the house but I didn't do it I just
sat there you know I bought one of those
TRX bands you know I'm gonna go on the
internet still have my custom workout
you know my shoulder feels really good
it's really strong I still haven't done
a pull-up in like two years
oh actually no I did and then re injured
it you know six months ago so now
rehabbing it back it's now I'm trying to
go nice and friggin slow I got these
bands now I'm back into doing yoga
I'm not [ __ ] JK I'm not there I said
it
I'm [ __ ] bored shitless I like people
who are sober how the [ __ ] you know you
know what I actually finally I bought an
external little CD player to plug in so
I could finally do my my rosetta stone
French and
I've been doing that then of course you
know my wife helps me set the [ __ ]
thing up and then I you know it's
working I'm having a great time and then
I go to use it again and of course it
won't [ __ ] work it doesn't recognize
anything I don't know how to open it up
it's just a [ __ ] painting yeah so
hopefully at some point she'll take some
time out of her day but anyways I'm
gonna polish up on that [ __ ] I'm trying
to do an hour to every single day right
up until I get over to France I just
want to get a little bit better with my
[ __ ] but uh you know at some point I got
I got a I got to learn I got to become
fluent in French cuz I just think a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like me knowing how to
speak French this is just something it's
too funny
to not do it right okay
I've actually ordered kids French books
and I'm reading them to my daughter
those are great because I was thinking
like well how did I learn how to read
English and speak it you know I had
those little books being in sandy sandy
at Bing remember though did they still
have those [ __ ] books they're like
these dogs that's what that is really is
one of the most fascinating things ever
is learning how to read and you're a kid
so you don't really remember like
something like teaches you how to
[ __ ] read all right let me see sandy
and Bing they were a dog and a cat see
this is a mammal going back 45 years
sandy and Bing books I swear to God if I
see these this is gonna freak me out to
see these books and of course it's not
coming up come on
yep hey the slowest goddamn internet
ever oh they don't even have them
anymore Oh Stanley Bing some guys
Stanley Bing wrote a book a hundred
[ __ ] jobs and how to get him that is
[ __ ] hilarious why the hell would you
do that why would you oh my God look at
this book the bent the Bernstein Bears
in the mean drunk
and there's a there's a bear I swear to
God wearing a wife-beater holding a bat
and it looks like a bottle of Jack
Daniels this is why you got to love the
Internet I'm looking up a kids book and
I find a hundred [ __ ] jobs and how
to get them and the Bernstein bears am I
saying that right
and the mean drunk bingo Crosby Anna
some Bugs Bunny one all right sorry what
the [ __ ] you guys illegally listened to
me surf the goddamn internet I've been
doing a bunch of stand-up and popping in
a bunch of places out here getting ready
for the gigs I have coming up that I do
not deserve to be doing in Ireland and
in London Dublin and in London so I'm
gonna make sure I'm beyond on my game
when I do those things I have a run of
dates coming up in San Francisco Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday I'm
gonna be up there with Nate Craig
Milwaukee Bucks fan I'm not gonna rub it
in unless he brings it up and I'll be
I'll be up there all week gonna find a
studio space with the drum kit I'm gonna
[ __ ] practice that [ __ ] I'll be
doing my French and I'm not gonna be
drinking and I'm not gonna be smoking
cigars boy I don't know there's no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna do this I guess
this is why people who were you know
somebody actually asked me that the day
if I wanted to go to a meeting you know
what I mean and I was just like dude I
can't sit there with all those [ __ ]
doughnuts and people smoking cigarettes
I'm just you know what I mean I'm just
not I'm not that you know like I'm
everything I ever [ __ ] joint I was
like I'm not this I'm not this I'm
liking this but I'm not quite this even
like playing drums as much as I love
playing drums I know I'm not a musician
like when I go you see you know when you
really see somebody that has the [ __ ]
gift you're like that's what that is I
mean I can try to do this and make a
really difficult life for myself
was until I walked into a comedy club an
open mic and I saw all those desperate
lunatics and I'm like yeah this is this
is me I'm this this is what I am so I
went to an a Amy I've gone to a couple
of them they were required by the
[ __ ] courts of Massachusetts I was
required to go to two of those and a
mother against drinking and driving way
back in the day when I got arrested for
that [ __ ] back in the 80s you know and I
remember sitting there listening to
these [ __ ] stories and I was just
like jesus [ __ ] christ
these people would have like head wounds
and wake up from head wounds or stumble
out of jail barefoot and just stumble
across the street directly over to a
liquor store I mean that is a [ __ ]
alcoholic you know they need help to
stop I can stop on my own am I just
justifying all of this that's what I've
everybody in the program's good I can
stop on my own and I just sit here I'm
just [ __ ] by just bored out of my
[ __ ] mind it doesn't make any sense
it's like I'm saying it that's like
saying I'm never gonna have ice cream
ever again it's like I could see not
having it all the time see not a fat
[ __ ] I get that so your teeth don't rot
out of your [ __ ] head I was
definitely drinking too much but like
I'm never gonna have it again I'm gonna
go to the Kentucky Derby again someday
god [ __ ] willing I'm gonna go to the
Kentucky Derby again and I'm gonna sit
there stone sober I mean you go into the
track I mean right there you're a
degenerate why not give in to it I don't
know who knows but I will tell you I do
love it in the morning when I wake up
clear-headed in the morning and my pasty
stomach is nice and flat I definitely I
definitely enjoy that you know makes me
a better dad I always make my daughter
breakfast that's my thing every morning
right I go out and I get her I open the
door and she goes hi my guy right
excuse me nice hug and a kiss
then you know changer put a pajama
bottoms across the rise where is she
where she plays that game loves it still
loving that game right and then I go
upstairs she's really easy I cut up
bananas strawberries and blueberries did
I make her a couple of eggs scrambled
it's funny what I like to do is I like
to have it all prepared before I bring
her upstairs because if I do you know
because if she's just sitting there she
starts to get restless like you know
where's the food but if I have it
already we other day I had it already
you know and I brought her up but I put
her in their little chair I put a bib on
and all that and I put the plate down
already ready and everything made and
she just goes Wow no she goes whoa it
was awesome and she can feed herself I
don't think I got to watch out for
she-wolf's down food the way I do so I
just got to make sure I'm uh staying on
her so I make sure I cut up everything
nice and small spread out the eggs so
they cool off she doesn't burn them off
and then that's it give her a glass of
water and it's all good so anyways you
know then I guess if I was hungover that
would probably be a bad thing so then I
think to myself what if I just get
shit-faced when I'm on the road I'm only
on the road like four days a month that
would be fine right what do you guys say
about that huh what do you say oh you
guys did [ __ ] AAA and I don't drink
on the plane it's just after the shows
it's got to be a way to do it the way I
used to be able to do it you know you
know you know what the really thing that
that [ __ ] me up was I I never used to
have booze in the house so that's the
problem so when I do start drinking
again because I am gonna start drinking
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna finish
all the liquor in my house which even if
I drank at a degenerate level would
probably take me a good six months so I
don't I don't know how I'm gonna do
probably have some people over and help
them kill some of these bottles but I
have such good booze I just can't give
it away to some bum you know what I mean
like you ever give a Cuban cigars
some guy who occasionally smokes and you
just watch him which is Huff the whole
[ __ ] thing down you know you might as
well give it him a Dutch master that's
the kind of booze I have so what I would
like to do is slowly knock out all the
booze over the next five years that I
have in the house and not replace any of
the bottles and then because I think
even back in the day when I lived in New
York when I was living in New York and
DeRosa was living in New York I mean we
used to just get [ __ ] annihilated and
but I never had any booze in the house
so in my apartment I should say so I
think that that's what I think that's
right there was the game-changers when I
had it at home and then I had these nice
[ __ ] glasses you know when you really
get into it like this is high-level
booze in these high level like you know
the right glass and you get into the
whole like ritual of it and you really
can trick yourself that you're not just
being some degenerate drinking alone you
don't immediately this is a highball
glass and this is what you do this glass
here is for Sam Adams beer I actually
have the Sam Adams glasses you know at
that little lip at the top like it's
supposed to make the head and the hops
and all of that taste but it tastes the
[ __ ] same you know I mean that's like
when they do all these reissues of
guitars you know what I mean I can't
tell the difference the way I play
guitar which I barely do anymore and you
know you could give me the greatest
guitar in the world I'm still gonna
sound like me which is shitty so anyways
I don't know who the [ __ ] knows but a
buddy mine's actually been listening to
these dis tapes that you know talk about
alcohol not that's stupid you need to go
to get help type away but they just
talked about they just put it in a
different perspective I don't know I'm
just like a streaky person that's all it
is so like when I'm not drinking I don't
want to drink cuz I don't want to ruin
the streak oh my god man I've gone like
35 40 days here I'm gonna start all over
again let me see if I can make it to 50
because there's a big part of me that uh
you know would like to plow right
through my birthday and not drink but
then it's like I'm gonna be in France
how the [ __ ] do you not drink when
you're over there I'm not gonna have a
[ __ ] glass of wine sit there like a
[ __ ] jerk-off I don't know we'll see
anyways all right zip recruits recruiter
talk about the challenge of finding
great talent and how the way you went
about it just did not work or was
inefficient well I'd love to tell you
that that was a problem but uh I
actually got lucky for somebody who was
a fan of my podcast reached out to me by
the name of Andrew chthamalus and I've
been working with him ever since you
know and he's been great so I don't know
what to tell you cause if recruiter knew
there was a smarter way well look
obviously if I actually ran a business
where I needed more than one friggin
employee okay and I don't want to waste
time bringing people in and sitting
there talking to them and trying to find
out if they came from divorce or you
know how they did in school or go go
check their goddamn Facebook page to see
what they've liked or not liked this
seems the easiest way to do it and you
can just if what sift through a entire
the entire nation of qualified
candidates well zip recruiter knew that
there was a smarter way so they built a
platform that finds the right job job
candidates for you zip learns what
you're looking for identifies people
with the right experience and invites
them to apply to your job these
invitations have revolutionized how you
find your next hire in fact eighty
percent of employees who post jobs on
zip get a quality candidate through the
site in just one day and zip recruit it
doesn't stop there they even spotlight
the strongest applications you receive
so you never miss a great match that's
right oh sorry the right candidates are
out there sip is how you find them call
to action business
of all sizes trust zip recruiter for how
their hiring needs right now my
listeners can try zip recruit it for
free that's right free just go to zip
recruit accom / / that's lip recruiter
comm / / zip recruiter dot-com / /
they're gonna do it again
zip the smartest way to hire I gotta
save my voice here cuz I gotta record
some efforts to a family f is for [ __ ]
today alright movement MVM tea movement
watches spring that's right around the
corner and movement is dropping all new
sunglasses to get you ready it's
dropping all new sunglasses to get you
ready for the warmer weather we just got
our go to shades for it all
who's week is that them is that supposed
to be me the guys at movement don't just
make great watches they also make
awesome sunglasses and just realized a
ton of new styles oh just released a ton
of new styles what is wrong with me
today alright here's my problem with
sunglasses evidently I got all these
cheap pairs that look terrible no I
don't I have nice sunglasses I have a
couple cheapos and I [ __ ] ate those
but every time I buy a $200 pair I feel
like I get ripped off that's not the
truth every time I spent $200 I end up
[ __ ] losing it or sitting on them or
dropping them on the pavement well our
friends at movement
yeah the watch guys they kind of felt
the same way so they thought screw it no
they're getting they're getting
dangerous here how about we make quality
trendy glasses at a fair price
these things aren't plastic they're
acetate acetate you can get them
polarized isn't there enough of that on
Facebook and they just start at $70 they
are seriously gonna be your go to shades
these are high-quality premium acetate
acetate acetate frames no cheap plastic
here you got to see these
they have lots of styles to choose from
classy trendy round aviator mirrored
polarized for him or for her you're sure
to find the perfect pair get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement dot-com
slash / you know movement for how
they've revolutionized the watch
industry now is the time to check out
their sunglasses go-to movement calm / /
join the movement oh [ __ ] the black tux
everybody like The Ohio State University
this is the black tux these are the
tuxedos that those people on a hiyo
State were wearing when they sold their
jerseys and got put on suspension
wedding season is upon us oh that's
right it is you're going to be doing it
big and going out to all of your buddy's
weddings I got to be honest with you
weddings are actually great now wedding
sucked when I was a kid because they was
still like people weren't making them
individual they just were all the same
they were long and [ __ ] boring and
you would like when can we get to the
bar when you're bringing a date you want
to look fresh but it has to be
convenient that's where the black tux
comes in dude you're not even in the
wedding and you gonna wear a tuxedo to a
wedding that's [ __ ] hilarious you
gonna out dress the groom I like the way
these people are thinking the black tux
has awesome suits and tuxedos and all
kinds of styles and you rent them online
oh I get it even wear a suit the B black
tux offers the kinds of suits and
tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly expensive to buy you might only
wear it once like the Emerald shawl
tuxedo it's funky it's cool but how many
times you gonna wear an emerald green
tuxedo with the black tux you can you
can do you and blow it out
for your one big event you're gonna wear
an emerald green tuxedo to somebody
else's wedding you know when you do that
you do that when you you used to be
[ __ ] the bride you know and she's
doing that douche move of inviting an
old boyfriend to the wedding Bridget's
friends we're at a good place by the way
is a man you cannot allow that to happen
you cannot allow that to happen
I mean I would actually question whether
I would even marry the person if they're
inviting an old boyfriend with the black
tux free home try on you can see the fit
and feel the quality of your suit months
before your event well you better make
sure you eat well if you're gonna try it
on that early after ordering your suit
will arrive 14 days before your event if
anything is less than perfect if you put
on a few pounds it took a few off I
guess the black tux will send you a
replacement right away well that's cool
and I'm about returns are where it turn
heads then send it back three days after
your event shipping is free Eve both
ways stand out at your event for the
right reasons with V black tux to get
$20 off your purchase visit V black tux
comm / / that's deep black tux comm / /
for $20 off your purchase the black tux
premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered all right one more here we go
stamps.com the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips
fingertips by imprint official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps comm makes it easy
they'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps comm will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs no need to leased an
expensive postage meter and there are no
long term commitments I use stamps comm
because you know whenever I send out my
postage which by the way you got to see
the poster for my tour coming up which
is simply called 50 all right the big
500 people and I am actually sending
posters over to Dublin and over to
London that's the first place the poster
that's where the tour officially gets
kicked off and I actually am not going
to be using stamps comm for that just
because the company's gonna be sending
it out themselves however when they send
me the rest of the posters and when I do
Minnesota and all that I will be using
stamps comm right and I'm a [ __ ] if I
can figure it out so can you and right
now you too can enjoy stamps - stamps
calm
service with a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus postage
and did a digital scale go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bird that
stamps comm enter ber and by the way in
Dublin and in London I will be coming
out after the show to take pictures and
sign your posts or something like that I
have not done in [ __ ] years I'm gonna
do that again because I appreciate you
guys coming out it is a big birthday why
not you know and God knows I'm not in
the back drinking although I think once
I get through Dublin and once I get
through London I think you know that's
would be June 6th I think that's the
night I might actually have a little uh
a little something who knows I don't
know but you know I'm bringing my whole
family over there I can't be hungover
that's another reason why my daughter is
the best right she keeps me sober
alright hang on one second I have to
look something up here because now we're
gonna get into the questions this week
and there's a point that somebody's
bringing it's the point that somebody's
bringing up about guns and they're doing
it in the usual way that people do it on
the Internet where they insult the other
person and I just want to make sure I
have the definition of something up here
okay
[ __ ] ar-15 response to goat guy for
those of you who don't listen all the
time
you know I you know there's a whole gun
debate why do you need an ar-15 so I was
asking people that have ar-15 I said why
do you have one and don't give me that
[ __ ] about [ __ ] you know home
defense and all of that crap I made
Jesus Christ I mean you could I mean you
could literally have a 22 only [ __ ]
anybody want to get shot by a [ __ ] 22
I would have a 22 I did a whole bit on
that just cuz I don't want to [ __ ]
blow my eardrums out I mean a [ __ ] BB
gun you know one of those little [ __ ]
co2 cartridges you shoot somebody in the
[ __ ] face with
I think the only thing a big key thing I
keep walking through that they can go
down the street and just don't have to
worry about anything when they walk into
that house I don't know anyways oh you
know or to fight off the government
that's my another famous one no that's
not my other favourite one you're gonna
fight off the government with your
[ __ ] semi-automatic gun here the
whole government you're gonna fight them
all off I got a lot of bullets
[ __ ] alright so anyway so this
guy ends up writing in saying that he
was a sheep farmer or whatever goat
farmer somewhat yeah go farmer and he
uses the milk to make
Parmesan Reggiano and he also or some
whatever the [ __ ] you use like two
different types of cheese I forget what
the other cut but both delicious types
of cheese and there's all these coyotes
and they hunt in packs and he's shooting
at a moving target and it just made
[ __ ] sense so then somebody else
wrote that guy that's [ __ ] just get
some [ __ ] dogs they'll fight off the
coyotes coyotes and cowards this guy's
full of [ __ ] and to be randomly killing
coyotes like that is you know mean and
all that so this guy is responding to
the person that responded to the gun
because I was impressed with that guy
when he said that this is why I use it
I'll go oh [ __ ] that makes sense and I
like that cheese so god bless you kill
those coyotes right so any was this
guy's responding to the person that said
that that guy still didn't need the gun
he could just get a couple of dogs so
anyways he said hey bill I'd like to say
to the guys response about just buy dogs
instead of an ar-15 does not know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about first of all
it's not a machine gun
you dumb [ __ ] its semi-automatic rifle
meaning you pull the trigger once and
one bullet fires okay now do you see how
he just made his point it's not a
machine gun you dumb [ __ ] it's a
semi-automatic rifle you should say it's
not a machine gun it's semi-automatic
and then you should explain what
semi-automatic means alright a
semi-automatic doesn't just mean that
you just pulled the trigger in one
bullet fires because then literally a
[ __ ] 38 is semi-automatic doesn't
that mean like you can you can actually
pull the
quickly faster where it won't get jammed
or something like that I mean there's
something difference between just a
[ __ ] revolver a semi-automatic and
fully automatic I don't know [ __ ] about
guns right but it isn't there so I
looked up semi-automatic firearm it says
this without calling anybody a dumb [ __ ]
you just not informed there's a lot of
information in the world you can't have
it all between your ears semi-automatic
firearm or a self-loading firearm is one
that not only fires a bullet each time
the trigger is pulled but also performs
all steps necessary to prepare it to
discharge again assuming cartridges
remain in the firearm feed device
typically this includes extracting and
ejecting the spent cartridge case from
the firing chamber rhe cocking the
firing mechanism and loading a new
cartridge into the fire firing chamber
to fire again the trigger is released to
fire again the trigger is released and
repressed again all right so now let me
ask you this so is is a 38 because the
revolver turns is that considered
semi-automatic now I'm just confused the
semi-automatic let me look up I mean let
me look this up is a revolver you know
it's funny people who are into gun right
now the amount of people that are
listening to me like I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like this means that they're better at
math it's like I don't know guns I don't
know anything about this [ __ ] if you
didn't know anything about drums I
wouldn't make funny because you know
what a [ __ ] hi-hat was this is a
revolver semi-automatic let's see here
and he hit search and it takes two hours
a revolver which uses multiple chambers
and a single barrel and a derringer
which uses multiple chambers in multi
barrows also fire one round per trigger
pull
but achieve this in different ways and
as such are not classified as being
semi-automatic
semi-automatic pistols a semi-automatic
pistol is a type of pistol that is
semi-automatic I swear to God that's the
first statement meaning it uses the
energy of the fired cartridge to cycle
the action of the firearm and advance
the next available cartridge into
position so basically if I don't have
some Revolutionary War thing that it's
just like I put a bullet in shoot and
then put another bullet in or I don't
have to do that cocking thing that you
always see with the sniper rifles
alright so this is sort of a basic gun
then this is like a car with power
windows and power brakes and power
steering like most cars have that now is
that basically what you're saying when
you were calling this guy a dumb [ __ ]
he's not a dumb [ __ ] I bet that that guy
what did this guy what if he's a
veterinarian that doesn't mean you're a
dumb [ __ ] alright you should have said
you uninformed [ __ ] how about that can
we can we meet in the middle there you
can still call him a [ __ ] but just used
to correct our adjectives anyways just
like most rifles and handguns these days
oh you actually explained it to me if I
considered continued reading okay first
of all it's not a machine gun you dumb
[ __ ] it's a semi-automatic rifle meaning
you pull the trigger once and one bullet
fires just like most rifle and handguns
these days right off the bat you know
this guy doesn't know what he's talking
about and probably never shot a gun in
his life fair enough yeah that's all
good I usually wouldn't be this hostile
but hey I had a few drinks and I'm
passionate about this subject alright
fair enough
anyway I believe his argument was to buy
a fleet of dogs to protect your
livestock he didn't say a fleet he said
you know I get like two or three he said
get the [ __ ] out of here you know
expensive trained dogs are to protect
your livestock I'm well do you or you
just drunk in a bar throwing this out I
mean Christ purebred German Shepherds
are eight and
$900 around here now you're a [ __ ]
no one's getting that German Shepard to
purr you get like a [ __ ] sheepdog or
like Christ one of my buddies has one of
those dogs they're smart as [ __ ] I
forget the name of the dog you wouldn't
you seen and now you don't know about
dogs your dumb [ __ ] the uninformed [ __ ]
God knows what a [ __ ] fleet of dogs
cost not to mention the food and
attention you have to give them ar-15
prices are going down every day and with
ammo well under 50 cents around you'd
have to be a dumbass oh Jesus
parentheses or a liberal not to use this
all right and right there your whole
argument is out the window
anybody who classifies all conservatives
or Republicans or all liberals and
Democrats is morons right there you know
what I mean that's kind of like what I
was doing earlier when I was talking
about how bad the officiating was
against the Bruins how I did bring up
that you know Marshawn should have got a
[ __ ] misconduct for taking that guy's
knees out and I did say that straight
across the board it was it's been really
[ __ ] unprofessional however but if I
were to just sit there and say all the
bad calls went against us I mean I don't
know I would be what kind of [ __ ]
world and kind of do a mass or a liberal
and I just made them out to all be
southerners like everybody down south is
a dumb ass which is not true Mark Twain
you don't to me that guy was so smart he
wrote all those books in Kentucky Fried
Chicken had that guy dressed just like
in conclusion he said in conclusion as
if he sees he's made this great argument
I think there is a huge lack of
education on firearms in the u.s. today
he actually wrote in the US today he
didn't capitalize the u.s. I
100% agree with that at the end of the
day the ar-15 is the most effective tool
for a lot of jobs PS I saw you in
Nashville your final bit [ __ ] killed
love you and go [ __ ] yourself sincerely
your freedom-loving fans in Nashville
dude you know something I got to be
honest with you I agreed with your
points but when you said dumbass or
liberal and the fact that you said
freedom-loving like who doesn't love to
be free you know what I mean are you
another one of these people that thinks
that Isis is a major threat to a first
world country with their no plane no
boat no uniform no real weaponry modern
weaponry [ __ ] army you know I mean do
you think if Isis was living in the
Badlands we would even waste a [ __ ]
second of our goddamn tax dollars to try
and stop them there's plenty of [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there they're just not sitting
on top of a bunch of [ __ ] oil
freedom-loving [ __ ] you know
something you really you really lost me
there
I mean if you don't agree with me I
guess you just don't like freedom boy
what the amount of people that are
drinking that [ __ ] kool-aid 15 years
into this [ __ ] thing it's a
liberation they have weapons of mass
destruction they've changed it like 90
[ __ ] times and I'm so sick of the fact
that you can't criticize what the [ __ ]
those [ __ ] broke-ass [ __ ] over there
are gonna bankrupt us how long can you
spend 700 billion dollars a [ __ ] year
at some point we're gonna have to pay
for that I'm gonna have to pay for it
you're gonna pay for it our kids their
kids and all of that jesus [ __ ]
christ over a bunch of jerk-offs with a
bag of m-80s
un-fuckin'-believable it's unbelievable
you know why we're over there Saddam
knew why we went over there he lit it on
fire before we got there but you can't
say that
anymore in this country because if you
do that means you're in Isis or you're a
socialist or some [ __ ] like that it's
just [ __ ] it's unbelievable
it's un-fuckin'-believable meanwhile
this place is going to hell in a
handbasket with a nationwide heroin
epidemic our food supply is [ __ ]
poison and the bankers got the houses
back so they can cook the economy again
all of that is fine but if you tell
jokes at a [ __ ] presidential whatever
the [ __ ] that is the whole goddamn world
stops all right this girl ah Billy
Blowfish love you Billy Blowfish you
like that love your podcast I've been
listening to it every time I'm in the
car driving to and from work definitely
makes my commute better listen I'm a 22
year old guy and I've been talking to
this girl who has a kid now I know what
you're thinking what the [ __ ] is going
through your stupid [ __ ] head but the
problem is is I think I really like this
girl I don't think that's a problem as
long as you're willing to take on the
responsibilities of that relationship is
nothing wrong with it and one thing I
forgot to mention I haven't even met her
in person yet okay I guess I just
dropped the microphone on that one I'm
supposed to meet her
I'm supposed to meet up with her all
caches thought you were stalking her on
social media I'm supposed to meet her
I'm supposed to go meet her up this
Saturday is that a new expression I
think he said I think he meant to say
meet up with her this Saturday night
after work and I'm not sure what will
happen the thing is she's exactly like
me
she's vegetarian she likes animals and
nature etc etc what's the nashville guy
doing right now yeah she likes all that
but does like freedom but she has a
[ __ ] kid bill I'm [ __ ] 22 years
old and can't stop thinking about this
girl who has a [ __ ] kid please give
me some advice
I'm not sure how to proceed well I think
you're very concerned with the
responsibilities of the fact that she
has a kid and what that's going to mean
and you're only 22 year
sold and this [ __ ] nothing wrong with
that okay and don't let all these
[ __ ] don't don't ask a woman about
this cuz she's just gonna stick up for
the [ __ ] woman because she's gonna
insert herself into that situation would
be like well I'd still like to be able
to find love just because I have a kid
dude you're 22 years old you are a kid
alright unless you're like really mature
or something like that that that is a
major detail that you should be thinking
about alright so I would respect the
fact that there's a voice in your head
that's saying dude she's got a [ __ ]
kid all right before you know because
I'm gonna tell you right now dude like
what you're getting involved in there
you know if that goes south you're gonna
break two hearts okay because there's
two people that are gonna fall in love
with you in that thing so make sure
you're you're prepared and you don't
waste her time and that poor kids time
alright so there you go that's my advice
to you this isn't you know oh look at
the tits I want to [ __ ] her this is not
that situation you know alright advice
dick the douche bag friend dear Billy
angel tits I don't know what that means
but anytime anybody calls me an angel I
take that as a compliment
I guess because there is white as an
Angels gown
maybe it's an insult I don't know Billy
red tits Billy devil tits you can go
either way on that love the podcast ah
thank you since you're always offering
great wisdom and words to live by I'm
really not I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and you
guys listen to me for some reason maybe
you could help me out with this one for
the sake of anima T hope I said that
right let's call this douchebag friend
of mine dick dick is the kind of person
that can get annoying and touchy towards
women when he's drunk to the point where
it starts to border on harassment it's
always weird it always weirds me the
[ __ ] out and I
know how to address this behavior simple
be like hey dick will you [ __ ] knock
it off what's wrong with you keep your
hands to yourself he goes a few weeks
ago we met this 18 year old girl at a
bar
what the [ __ ] she doing at a bar which
we had a great time with we all went to
dicks house afterwards for a couple more
dicks drinks re-indict
tried to make some moves on this girl he
couldn't get into her pants that night
however however last Friday he did now
this is where it gets crazy
the next day he took the girl to a
yearly festival to celebrate liberation
day where he and I and a whole bunch of
friends had planned to meet up this is
obviously from another country I don't
know a liberation day she basically only
knew me and him about 15 minutes into
meeting each other there the girl
started puking up foam as it turns out
she hadn't eaten all day and had popped
a pill of ecstasy which he had given to
her oh my god he didn't seem to care
what was happening so I decided to take
her to the bathroom area to clean her up
and I brought her some water and then we
went back to look for dick well why
would you take her back to him when we
finally found him let me guess he was
trying to hook up with somebody else I
told dick like dude she hasn't eaten all
day man she was puking back there and
you should get her something to eat and
what did this [ __ ] do he quickly
walked away and left me to deal with
this 18 year old chick for the rest of
the entire day we didn't see him again
for the rest of the day and we made no
effort in trying to he made no effort in
trying to find us what a dick being the
gentleman that I am I decided to stay
with her to guide her through this
ecstasy trip I gave her some food and
tried to have fun and even though we did
have fun it had already ruined that day
for me he tried to contact me today but
I'm really questioning whether he even
deserves respond what do you think bill
should I give this dick another chance
or is just the kind of person you want
to cut out of your life completely
thanks I'll tell you this is the nope
Rayner I pick up the phone and I would
just tell them like dude you are a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and your behavior around women is
completely unacceptable to the point I
would warn other women to stay away from
you and I don't want to be friends with
the person like you have a nice life and
God bless the United States of America
and that's it that's an easy one I don't
have to think about that one all right
[ __ ] banks bill I'm writing to you
because I believe you are the only man
crazy and angry enough to relate with me
on this dude [ __ ] banks [ __ ] them all
this month I just found out I owe my
bank $45
apparently fitness connection attempted
to withdrawal ten dollars from my
account these past two months once a
month I had about five dollars in my
bank two months ago
this could not cover the ten dollar fee
a month for my gym membership twice so
now I'm being charged a fee of $40 five
dollars even though one its debit to
fitness didn't actually withdraw the
money they only attempted to nothing
went through so not only do I owe my
bank $45 but I also hold fitness
connection about 50 in late fees and the
$2 to $10 fees that never got paid
please explain to me why I'm being
charged for this transaction that didn't
go through is there a guy working in the
dark room at the bank pushing buttons
who they have to pay for the transaction
services no it's all [ __ ] ones and
zeros all computers yet another fee that
we as consumers except for no reason at
all even if it makes no sense the idea
of letting an entity such as a bank
holds your money seems to carry way more
cons than it does parks taking your
advice and I'm going to call and
complain until I get what I want
[ __ ] banks forever now all my money
lives in the walls if the house burns
down then so be it but at least I didn't
get [ __ ] by the man keep the good work
and good luck to your Celtics Jason
Statham is looking like a baller
all right I agree with a lot of things
you're saying there but what you didn't
take responsibility for was your own
actions that led to this all right if
you know that you owe your gym $10 a
month you're gonna have to [ __ ] have
that in your bank account you didn't
have that so then I don't know how it
works I know if you write a check then
it bounces there's a fee so you're
saying this is debit but you're using
your debit like paying cash and
everything so I actually don't think
banks are out of line for doing that by
what I think is you need to be more
responsible with your money and like I
agree with you banks are [ __ ] evil
it's a giant Ponzi scheme there's
nothing behind the [ __ ] money but
everybody believes in it so hey we live
another day all right but the thing
about it is is you have to learn to make
money work for you and if you don't
understand money the wonderful thing
about the Internet is if you stop you
know reading people screaming about
politics or watching online porn and all
of that [ __ ] which I've been guilty of
all of that stuff there's actually a lot
of things you can learn and what I've
learned about money is that money can
set you free or it can imprison you and
it all depends on the choices that
you're making and the choices that
you're making sir
are horrific and back in the day would
have landed you and all of your family
into debtors prisons so you got off easy
in the modern world you know I guess
taking your money out of the banks you
know putting in your walls I you know I
I don't disagree with that past a
certain amount of [ __ ] money but I I
like to invest in things that are
intangible I'm into real estate I'm into
buying apartment buildings and [ __ ] like
that
you always have to hedge your bets like
I'm buying apartment buildings just
starting to do that I was like I bought
a bunch of looking at one right because
it fascinates me
to have income coming into my house
every month that's not actually in the
business that I'm in and the business
that I'm in now considering now with
social media somebody can just say you
did something and there's no
what-do-you-call there's no due process
or anything and that could literally
cause everybody in the business you're
in to just walk away from you and then
then what do you do you know so and
that's just a new pitfall in this [ __ ]
up business that I'm in what's you know
even before all that me to [ __ ] I mean
you see these movie stars one hit after
another one after another and all of a
sudden they have a couple of flops in a
row and then they just disappear so this
business has always been fickle as hell
so I planned on doing this anyways but
after all of that stuff came out and
like you know just recently looking at
Tom Brokaw stuff I don't know if he's
guilty or innocent but the fact that two
people can just accuse him and which is
totally their right but the amount of
people that just on the accusations now
just look at that guy like he's a
complete piece of [ __ ] is isn't right is
it isn't any more right than if he
actually did what they said they were
doing and then he's actually guilty of
it but to just you know an accusation is
just an accusation but the amount of
people that then take that as you know
game set match is I mean it's just how
the world works
it's just how it works so you need to
learn about money can't just say [ __ ]
banks and then just be antisocial and
have your like money in the walls I mean
you can use banks as long as you know
what what what the game is you can use
it in your favor and and if you just
resist the stupidity of consumption in
flat-screen TVs and all of this [ __ ]
that these stupid [ __ ] celebrities
show you when they go into the
houses you know I had this stupid they
all what they're showing you is a
[ __ ] the only thing that's impressive
is the house everything else is a
deposit is a liability it's all
depreciating assets they're [ __ ] cars
all of that [ __ ] you don't I mean those
stupid supercars that that's [ __ ]
idiots buy that you know the only place
you really should be taking it is to a
track so you can actually you know open
the thing up and then all of those cars
like you know you look at those Ford GTS
I saw one the other day for sale and it
was like [ __ ] ten fifteen years old
and it was high miles it had 6,000 miles
on it now it retained most of its value
but it's just I don't know I guess
unless you're gonna buy those things but
all of those flat-screen TVs the
monogram [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] the oil
painting yourself it's just a bunch it's
a bunch of [ __ ] it's [ __ ] stupid the
pots and pans that you buy that rather
than just buying the ones that target
you go out and you got to go to [ __ ]
foofy folks in place and get by these
gourmet level [ __ ] pots and pans to
heat up your fish sticks because at the
end of the day is still that blue-collar
jerk-off it's all a [ __ ] waste of
money and it's just a bunch of [ __ ] now
if you actually take your money right
you know and and learn how to invest it
and then your money starts making money
that's when you flip it when your money
is earning you [ __ ] money when you're
[ __ ] sitting on a couch watching a
game and your money is out there and
making you [ __ ] money then you
understand and I mean I don't even
understand it okay but I'm just starting
to learn how to do it and the the I
don't they just it's nowhere in the
educational system you have to seek out
that knowledge yourself like most
quality knowledge that's out there you
have to seek it out because people
aren't going to give it to you so that's
what I would say so
I feel whew that you're inept
I've been in that position but I
wouldn't say [ __ ] banks use banks rather
than have banks use you all right there
you go there's a long explanation but an
important subject all right my sister's
deadbeat boyfriend
dear Tara Billie I mean what that means
I'm a I'm a junior in high school and I
live with my mother sister and a
deadbeat boyfriend Wow he moved in with
intentions to pay rent and help fix up
our house that is slowly falling apart
is his Dwight Yoakam from [ __ ]
Slingblade but for the past year this
losers had no job in fence paid no rent
yeah yeah he's a gold-digging [ __ ] all
he does is sleep all day and play xbox
he also mentally manipulates my sister
by telling her things like her family
doesn't care enough about her to give
her a funeral oh my god you got to get
this guy out of the house while he gets
high in drunk and totes his guns around
my mom has on multiplication threatened
to kick him out because she but she
won't in fear that my sister will go
with him what in the [ __ ] is I I don't
even understand how a parent loses this
level of control in their own house so
bill what do you think I should do about
this situation thank you for being so
damn fine thank you all right
looking forward to visiting family
season three what do you think I should
do you got to sit down and talk to your
mom and you just say mom I know this is
a difficult situation but you got to
kick this guy out of the house he's
drunk and he's he's walking around with
guns you got to choose your family first
and if our sister chooses him over us
then so be it
I mean that's it - you got to get that
guy out of the [ __ ] house - [ __ ] that
loser that's it these are all cut and
dries this week dump that [ __ ] douche
that banded that chick after he gave her
the ecstasy Lauren you know learn how to
[ __ ] use money correct
get this [ __ ] guy out of the house
Jesus Christ I feel like I'm cheating on
a test here these are easy this week sit
down with your mom and just say we got
to kick this guy out and this is what I
would do I would if you need to I would
call the cops before you kick him out if
you think he's gonna be a problem I
would have the cops come down there and
say I don't want this guy in my house
anymore he does have firearms and I want
him out of the house what a [ __ ]
loser
all right dumped because of infidelity
20 years ago
big Billy Bald balls massive fan of the
podcast and your specials have had me in
stitches oh thank you
I really need your opinions opinions
last advice on a situation with recent
issues I've just broken up with an
amazing lady the woman I was going to
propose to this month we have been to
get together eight months but when you
get to your late 30s you can cut through
the [ __ ] pretty quickly and get to a
meaningful relationship I knew she was
the one I wanted to spend the rest of my
life with our relationship had been
great no arguments lots of fun laughter
and love only one issue existed between
us and it seems to have caused the end
of the relationship not long after we
started dating we were out having drinks
and we were talking lately about past
relationship and she asked if I had ever
been unfaithful I wanted to be honest
and said yes she asked to know more and
I described a time when I was 20 and I
had been an idiot and cheated on my
girlfriend at the time I stressed that I
regretted it and I've never entertained
the thought of doing that again I am
simply not the same guy she reacted very
badly leaving the pub crying outside
before coming back in and telling me she
wished I'd lied we managed to get past
it though that night don't you with 20
relationship went on as normal we shared
many weekends and all these fun nights
out cozy nights in talked about a future
together and I was invited to share
Christmas and New Year's with their
entire family was great even as recently
as last week she was redesigning my
garden for use in the summer it is
reared its head two more times since
then once on my birthday in January when
we nearly broke up over it and she was
struggling with it again she was so
upset kept saying why couldn't you have
just lied but we talked through and
moved on again or so I thought and then
of course recently when it all ended
every time it has come up I've been
honest and shown true remorse and been
very supportive very recently we broke
up because she just can't get past my
past and said it's the only thing
stopping her from committing to me fully
she loves me wanted to be talking about
having children with me bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla I don't even
read lessons
everywhere you look all you hear is the
once a cheater always a cheater lines
which in my case simply was not true I
know that some of this stems from one of
her past relationship which ended in
2016 when she was engaged and the guy
broke it off and ran off with one of her
friends I don't want to lose this lady
only back on Valentine's Day she made me
present only back up Valentine's Day she
made me a present of a lot of reasons
why she loves me one of them was that
she thinks about the future she only saw
it with me and then I made her feel like
no one else has this can surely be saved
but I don't understand it and I don't
know what to do
thanks Bill and go [ __ ] yourself well I
mean what the [ __ ] can you do I mean if
she's gonna judge you by what you did
when you were 20 years old I just laid
on tables that listen I want to marry
you
alright there's nothing I can do to make
you know I'm paying for the sins of that
last guy and if you want to throw this
relationship because of that away
because of that last guy that's on you
dude you've done all you can do here you
done all you can do here so she's
obviously not over that other guy or the
pain of that other guy and now you're
paying for it I don't know so I mean
what the [ __ ] can you do I would just
tell her how I feel about her and just
say listen I'm ready to get married any
time you want to but if you don't then
you got to let me go and I got to move
on I got to get you know cuz I'm in my
late 30s and if you don't trust me
enough that I'm not gonna [ __ ] around on
you then I you know I don't want to tell
you then I guess it is over but it's
gonna be your call it's not my call
something like that I don't know that's
a tough one buddy all right the last one
last one yet Jesus is a long podcast did
I blow my chances with this girl from
work hello Bill Nye the angry guy I'll
keep this as short as I can who just
opened that door hey buddy hey what's up
cutie pie
I guess I'm watching you right now hi
[Music]
what's going on don't pull the cord
don't don't pull the cord all right yeah
help me out with this one this guy's
acid did I blow my chances with this
girl from work hello Bill Nye the angry
guy I'll keep this short as I can I work
with this girl that is a solid ten she's
absolutely gorgeous and a personality
matches mine in a hundred different ways
and she's a nerdy chick which is a
massive plus if you saw her you'd say
holy s why does she work in a place like
this can't curse my kids here quick and
simple I got to know her we constantly
flirted back back and forward not back
and forth Nia
they flirted back and forward she put a
lot of attention on me not to sound
egotistical but I'm a good-looking I
thought he said 62 year old guys six
foot two guy my issue is that when I get
too comfortable I began to spill my red
flags and I start to describe my
self-confidence issues I guess I do this
to see if she's okay with them bad move
yes it is after working with her for
nearly a year and a half now
she seems distant yeah
we waited too long we used to watch the
same shows not physically together but
then come to work the next day and have
long conversations about how awesome
they were she used to make efforts to
initiate conversation now she barely
acknowledges me anymore it was really
sudden well she probably met someone I'm
not trying to be a dick here I've tried
a lot to strike up conversation but she
acts disinterested I started trying to
make her jealous but she doesn't seem to
give a f we work in a almost exclusive
male workplace so of course everyone is
trying to get with her
it burns my blood to watch it but it's
my fault is there anything I can do to
reserve reverse my situation or if I
sealed this case shut thanks for reading
please come - I'm not going to say the
city in case she's listening yeah I
think you blew it with her the only your
work girlfriend broke up yeah I think
what you need to do is move on and stop
talking about your confidence issues you
need to get some confidence you need to
get outside the workplace and you need
to start hitting on some women and you
need to go on dates and then you're
gonna feel more confident about yourself
and that's the best way to try to make
this woman more interested in you all
right don't ask where you eat yeah
yeah because yeah exactly exactly well
this guy doesn't have confidence so he's
not gonna walk up to a woman that he
doesn't really know he needs to get over
that hump hump which is why it worked
because there's a reason they're
supposed to be there he feels more
comfortable and he you know she was
probably waiting for him to ask around
and then he didn't and then now it
sounds like she's with somebody else
yeah or she's just over his just over it
you know that old fun I guess I'd work
boyfriend girlfriend relationship and
she's moved on there you go yeah so yeah
do plenty of fish in the sea you know
and don't waste your time getting
jealous but this person just like you go
in there you know you don't care hi bye
yeah what's up smiley uh hi it's funny
now as she speaks gibberish but she
knows exactly what she's saying and then
she'll just throw in a random real-world
she like I said hi stories all right
that's the podcast for this week go you
know what yourselves and I'll check in
on you on Thursday
yeah congratulations to the Tampa Bay
Lightning you be a bunch of bees
all right I'll talk to you later